webrtc exchange real-time audio video
streams with your friends
entirely in the browser i'm here live
that's not i'm not a cat
if you want to build your own video
conferencing app to capitalize on the
work from home boom
then webrtc is the api you're looking
for because it allows you to establish a
peer-to-peer connection between two or
more browsers
where they can exchange audio video
media directly without the need for a
third-party server or native app
it works like this the first pier will
create an offer
asking for another peer to connect to
them this will result
in an stp object or session description
protocol
which contains information describing
the peer-to-peer connection
like the video codec timing and so on
the data will then be saved in a server
where it can then be read by another
peer to answer the call which is
achieved by creating an stp answer
and writing that to the server this
process is known as
signaling and it's handled by a third
party server the signaling server allows
the two parties to securely exchange
connection data
but never touches the media that's
actually transmitted between the peers
but here's where things get tricky most
devices in the real world sit behind
firewalls
and ip addresses constantly change
thanks to network address translation
this makes peer-to-peer connection
complicated from a networking standpoint
but luckily there's a standard called
interactive connectivity establishment
or ice which helps clients coordinate
the discovery of their public-facing ip
addresses
now both peers will generate a list of
ice candidates
which contain an ip address and port
that pier 1 can use to connect to pier
2.
in the background webrtc will do this by
making a series of requests to a stun
server
a stun server is not something you need
to set up on your own because there are
many free options out there
from reliable sources like google each
peer will save their ice candidates in
the database where they can then be read
by the other peer
the algorithm will then automatically
determine which candidate is best
at which point real-time media can begin
flowing between the two peers
this has been webrtc in 100 seconds if
you want to see more short videos like
this
make sure to hit the like button then
stay tuned because now we're going to
build our own video chat app from
scratch
that may sound pretty complicated but
the webrtc api
allows all this stuff to magically
happen in the background over the next
few minutes you'll build a peer-to-peer
video calling app from scratch
using nothing but vanilla javascript and
firebase as the signalling server
by the end of this tutorial you'll know
how to implement real-time features that
cater to the needs of the new work from
home paradigm that we live in
in addition to this video you can also
reference the full article on fire ship
io
and the source code on github let's
start by taking a look at the demo
we have the local user's video feed on
the left side and the remote video
on the right side the local user will
first grant permission for the app to
access the webcam
that user can then create a call which
will write a document to firestore with
the offer details
at the same time we'll create a peer
connection instance in the browser
which handles the webrtc negotiation
process
the offer will have a unique id that can
then be accessed by another user
somewhere else in the world
that user will then join the call with
the unique id then establish their own
peer connection
and write the answer details to the same
document
then both peers will write their ice
candidates to the database we have one
sub-collection for offer candidates
and another for answer candidates this
data model will allow signaling to
take place between the two peers the
data itself looks like a bunch of
nonsense but what it contains is an ip
address port pair that allows the two
peers to establish a connection
now both users can listen to this data
in real time then use the web rtc api in
the browser to establish the connection
giving us a one-to-one video chat
feature and now we're ready to jump into
our javascript code i started by
creating a vanilla javascript project
using a tool called veet which is a very
simple build tool developed by the
vue.js guy
we can initialize a new project by
running npm init
vjs app from the command line basically
it gives us a web project where we can
install dependencies without having to
worry about things like webpack
after initializing the project we need
to install firebase
firebase contains the firestore database
which we can use as our backend
signaling server
firebase is an exceptional choice for a
signalling server because it's easy to
listen to updates to the database in
real time
if we were working with a traditional
database we'd likely have to implement
something like websockets to make that
possible and this video would be a crazy
20 minutes long or something
from the firebase console initialize
firestore in test mode
then create a web project from the
settings panel and grab your project
credentials
we can then go into the main.js file
import firebase
and initialize the app with our firebase
config now that we have firebase set up
we're going to initialize three pieces
of global state these are values you
would likely want to share between
multiple components if you're using a ui
framework like react or angular
the first and most important value is
the rtc peer connection
this object is where all the action
happens it emits a bunch of different
events that we can listen to
to update the database and to add media
streams to the connection itself
one very important thing it does is
generate the ice candidates
but in order to do that it needs to know
which stun servers to use
there are many different options out
there but we're just going to use the
free ones from google
from there we have values for local
stream and remote stream
which are the video streams from the
webcams of each user
now because we're working with vanilla
js we need to use imperative dom apis
we're using document git element by id
to grab a bunch of elements from the
html
like video elements to show the actual
video feeds
along with buttons that provide
different interaction in the ui the
first thing the user will do is click a
button
to open up their webcam we'll go ahead
and register an event handler for the
click event on the webcam button
obtaining a stream from the user's
webcam is very easy we just await
the navigator media devices get user
media method
and we'll set video and audio to true
that'll bring up a dialog in the browser
asking the user for permission to access
the webcam when that's complete
the promise will resolve to a media
stream object once we have access to the
webcam
we can also go ahead and set up the
remote stream here
which itself will just be an empty media
stream now from here we need to take our
two streams
and make them available on the peer
connection and show them on
video elements in the dom the local
stream is already running here in the
browser
so we can get its tracks and then loop
over them and for each track
we'll call peer connection ad track with
that track and the local stream
now the remote stream is currently empty
and it will be updated by the peer
connection itself
so what we can do is listen to the on
track event on the pure connection
then get the tracks from the stream loop
over them and add them to the remote
stream when they come in
now the final step for managing our
streams is to apply them to video
elements in the dom we can do that by
simply calling the video element source
object
and setting it equal to the stream at
this point we have a way to manage a
local and remote stream through the peer
connection
but in order to make that happen we need
to do some signaling with firestore
the user who starts a call is the one
who makes an offer we have a call button
in the dom to
handle that functionality inside this
async function here
we have a call document which is used to
manage the answer and offer from both
users
then we have offer candidates and answer
candidates which are sub collections
under that document
that contain all the candidates for each
of those users
when we reference a document without an
id firebase will automatically generate
a random id for
us so we'll go ahead and use that to
populate an input in the ui
which can then be used in another
browser tab or by another user somewhere
else in the world to answer the call
now we're ready to create an offer and
save it to the database
the first thing we'll do is await the
peerconnectioncreateoffer method
which will return us with an offer
description we'll then set it as the
local description on the peer connection
most importantly this object contains an
sdp value
which stands for session description
protocol that's the value we want to
save to the database so we'll go ahead
and convert it to a plain
javascript object then write it to the
database by calling await
call document set with that data now
what's inside the sdp
object isn't really important but it
contains information about the video
codec
along with a bunch of other stuff to
negotiate the connection now one really
important thing to point out here
is that when we called set local
description it automatically started
generating the ice candidates
an ice candidate contains a potential ip
address and port pair
that can be used to establish the actual
peer-to-peer connection
we need to be listening to the ice
candidates so it's important that we
have a listener established before we
make that call
that listens to the on ice candidate
event when the event is fired we'll make
sure that a candidate
exists then write the data as json to
the offer candidates collection
so at this point as the caller making
the offer we are saving all of our data
to the database
but now we need to also be listening for
the answer from the user on the other
end
the way we do that is by listening to
changes to the called document in
firestore
the on snapshot method will fire a
callback anytime the document in the
database changes
if our peer connection doesn't have a
current remote description
and the data has an answer then we'll go
ahead and set an
answer description on our peer
connection here locally
in other words we're listening to our
database for an answer and when that
answer is received we update it on our
peer connection
that negotiates the initial connection
but we also need to listen for ice
candidates from the answering user we do
that by listening to
updates to the answer candidates
collection firestore has a cool little
feature where you can listen to
only the documents that have been added
to the collection which is handled with
the doc changes method on the query
so every time we have a new document
added we can then create a new ice
candidate with the document data
and then add that candidate to our peer
connection
at this point we're listening to updates
from the answer side but we still need
to give the answer and user a way to
actually answer the call answering a
call is very similar to initiating a
call
the main difference is that we're going
to listen to a document in firestore
with the same document id that was
created by the caller we'll make a
reference to that document
as well as the answer candidates
collection then listen to the ice
candidate event on the peer connection
to update the answer candidates
collection whenever a new candidate
is generated from there we can fetch the
call document from the database
and grab its data it contains the offer
data which we can use to set
a remote description on the peer
connection after that
we can then generate an answer locally
then set the local description as the
answer
now just like we did with the offer in
the previous function we'll set it up as
a plain object
and then update it on the call document
so that the other user can listen to the
answer
in addition we'll set up a listener on
the offer candidates collection
and whenever a new ice candidate is
added to that collection
then we'll go ahead and create an ice
candidate here locally
and that's all it takes to build a video
chat feature with webrtc
the vast majority of the work is just
signaling data between the two users
webrtc handles all the complicated
peer-to-peer networking and media
streaming under the hood
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe
and if you want to learn more advanced
concepts about the web and firebase
consider becoming a pro member at
fireshipio
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one